so we're finally going to hear from
James Comey the former FBI director who
was fired by Donald Trump with Trump's
goal for Trump's goal to serve Trump's
objective of interfering stopping even
potentially the investigation into Trump
Russia collusion obstruction and
possible financial crimes the interview
has already been filmed it's gonna be an
ABC 20/20 special airing this Sunday
Comey was interviewed by George
Stephanopoulos and if we are to believe
the sources who were in the room for the
recording of the interview it is going
to be a wild Monday after the interview
airs over the weekend according to
sources in the room when the interview
was taped Comey answered every question
directly and fully his answers will
reportedly quote shock the president and
quote add more meat to the charges
swirling around Trump people in the room
were reportedly quote stunned by what
Comey said to George Stephanopoulos
during the interview others said that it
was quote surreal to hear what Comey was
saying and Comey reportedly likens Trump
to a mob boss during the interview
what skepticism should we bring to this
interview I would say all of it in other
words we should bring our normal
skepticism that all of us as hopefully
informed and savvy and critical
consumers of news would bring to any
media interview and in particular to one
where the subject in this case James
Comey has a book to sell which comes out
less than 48 hours after the interview
airs so am I looking forward to this
absolutely I'm looking forward to it
will I accept everything that James
Comey says without any critical
assessment obviously not obviously not
do I think James Comey has a history of
lying like is he a systemically
unreliable and dishonest person sort of
like the current President of the United
States no he's not but my major
skepticism is mostly stemming from the
idea
that Comey has had these bombshells for
months and they are calculated to be
released in an interview right before
his book launch can I really fault the
guy for it I don't know I mean most
people would do this most people do
stuff like this doesn't mean I like it
doesn't mean that it's a great thing but
it doesn't go to the accuracy or
inaccuracy of what Comey will say but
yeah if he's telling the story merely
for love of country he could have told
the story two months ago
rather than waiting for the impending
impending release of his book to happen
within fewer than 48 hours of when the
interview will air I don't doubt that
came that Comey is doing it for what he
sees his love of country but he's also
partially doing it to sell books and
this really relates you know we've been
talking about Syria I talked about it
yesterday and talked about it today we
talked about the robert muller referral
of information about trump's lawyer
michael cohen to prosecutors who got a
warrant from a judge and then actually
served that search warrant at Cohen's
office as well as his New York City
hotel room all of these things might not
be separate right Trump's increasingly
belligerent tweets about Syria whatever
you think about the policy he's sort of
suggesting there this could all be
related to the Michael Cohen thing and
an attempt to distract this could be
related to you know we it's very
possible that Trump got word of the
Comey interview 12 24 or 36 hours before
news leaked of the stunned and and
surreal quotes from people in the room
and that this is yet another attempt
when it comes to Syria or whatever else
Trump is tweeting about immigration or
Democrats that the normal distract the
thon attempts it all could be a
pre-emptive attempt to distract from
what it is that we're going to learn
from the James Comey interview we can't
underestimate the lengths Trump is
willing to go to in order to
preemptively take attention away from
really really bad things breaking in the
media so I will be watching the
interview I think there's going to be
endlessly fascinating
but I am NOT going in just assuming that
everything James Comey said should be
uncritically accepted but I am going in
with the understanding that James Comey
is not a historically dishonest guy and
we will see what ultimately comes of it
today's program is sponsored in part by
shaker and spoon the monthly cocktail
subscription box that delivers the craft
cocktail experience directly to your
door every month shaker and spoon sends
you the ingredients for three completely
new original craft cocktails for a total
of 12 cocktails enough for the whole
month I got the death by gin box which
was really great it came with a number
of different ingredients including
lemons and limes as well as chai syrup
and persimmon and bitters all sorts of
really great stuff that I would never
know how to combine if it were up to me
but it comes with really great and clear
recipe cards which you follow after
choosing the brand of spirit of your
choice this is actually a really cool
gift my girlfriend decided to gift a
shaker and spoon subscription to a
friend of hers who really likes craft
cocktails for her birthday it's super
easy all you need to know is the
recipients email address and you can do
a 1 3 6 or 12 month subscription for
that person the gift T can also wait to
claim their gift until they see a box
that they like they choose when to start
the subscription instead of it just
showing up at their door all of a sudden
and for a limited time you can get $20
off by going to shaker and spoon comm
slash Pakman